i can't take that advice because it's
not a very hollywood ending
and she tells him well
hollywood ending all depends on where
you stop the story
what are ways that a writer can create
high stakes for their character ooh
it's a good question um
it has to be well first of all it has to
be something that relates to their wound
right it has to be some
kink in their armor where
uh
this makes it personal for them
it has to be that that's number one
and because overall the story is about
them overcoming that wound and that
somehow tying into
this goal of stopping whatever the
antagonist is
so but the stakes have to be high enough
where it almost seems insurmountable
you know so yeah i believe that you know
the stakes are very important but it has
to be
all relatable to the character into the
audience
okay so
if it's something that's too avant-garde
we can't understand it but if it's just
sort of about the basic needs of living
safety security
then we can relate to it
i think it can be
almost anything it all depends on who
you are who your core audience is
um
for
just giving example for once and one
right if you if you watch the film it's
it's very easy to sit back and go i what
i don't really get it but the story is
very meta it's it's very meta this
there's a story happening
and then there's a story that the writer
is writing
but unbeknownst to him
they both are the same story
okay
and in the story that he's trying to
write that he's having writer's block
with the reason why he can't relate is
because he's
cut so many pieces of himself away to
fit in right to fit in with
this life with his wife this new
hollywood life
he was doing it before when he was
trying to do sales he's just trying to
fit in with everybody with his friends
he keeps cutting off pieces of himself
to the point where he doesn't recognize
himself anymore okay and he's not honest
with himself
without honesty and he doesn't know
himself he doesn't even know what he
wants
he's writing a script that he can't he
can't finish it it seems convoluted
there's all this other stuff going on
inside the story that he's writing is
about a guy who's robbing a bank
he wants the money
then there's his girl that he meets
inside of the bank he starts falling for
the girl there's the police outside the
police are going to make him pay for
whatever he does right
if he
wants the girl he has to give up the
money because she doesn't like stealing
and all that other kind of stuff if he
takes the money he loses the girl and
all of that the police are still outside
how is he going to get past that
in both of these stories it's not even
knowing what the guy wants
the guy doesn't know what he wants he's
all over the place right
and what you begin to realize is for the
protagonist and the story
his wife
is
really related to the money in the story
that's his security
he's so secure with his wife because
she's on a sole property she makes lots
of money
he can be a struggling writer and it
doesn't matter
so he has that in the movie that's money
that's security
right
and then he meets this girl named pia
and he's completely infatuated by her
it's exciting and it's new well that's
the girl in the story it's exciting and
it's new
he's always needed money and security
but excitement has taken over does he
choose excitement
and then of course the woman's husband
who's his best friend
is the police
that's the people who are gonna hold him
accountable
they're gonna
he's gonna he's gonna have to suffer a
consequence whether it's good or bad
he's gotta suffer a consequence
that friend is gonna make him pay he's
making him pay the whole movie when
you're watching you're just like geez
you almost considered
the friend to be the bad guy until you
realize this guy has a wife but he's
infatuated with this other woman right
and that's the dance that is going on in
this entire film
so
i look at it and i go you know
the film may be hard to understand it
may be hard to understand uh
how to relate to it and how this relates
to you but for a specific group of
people they'll understand that desire to
fit in
and that you don't even know yourself
and that you're driven by what you want
in the moment but do you even really
want it do you know yourself enough to
know you really want it
and
i think there is a segment of audiences
that can relate
you know but then they'll also be a
segment that'll say i don't even get any
of this it's because they don't relate
to any of it
they just don't but that movie's not for
them
sure or maybe they've seen that in
someone close to them
or or they used to be that and then they
realize all that's empty but but i i see
what you mean someone that's really
conflicted they want what they want
they're willing to kind of sell their
soul for it yeah yeah i think that's a
that's a good story to write about
hollywood mm-hmm
it is and it's him he's he's he's
he's just in the wind because he doesn't
know himself anymore
sure he doesn't
how long did it take you to write the
script
i started writing it
in probably
2017 2018 i started writing it
but it was one of those ones where i
just kind of plugged away at it for a
little bit at a time and then i got to a
point where i said i i don't know
where i should take this story and then
what happened was i put it aside for a
moment
and i went off and i did some other work
and it was around that time that i
realized man you know the reason why i
didn't know where to go with this story
was because i was trying to
[Music]
stick a hollywood ending on it
and it's funny because that's actually a
line in the earlier in the script is
that he was saying you know he's taking
advice from the character p and he says
i can't take that advice because it's
not a very hollywood ending and she
tells them well
hollywood ending all depends on where
you stop the story
and so
i i said to myself i have to be honest
in the rest of the screenplay i have to
be honest and i have to make him have
real conversations about
where he's headed where his
relationships are headed where his life
is headed he has to have these real
conversations now he can't have them the
way that we have them
but he has to have them
and he has to make a decision
it can't be ambiguous he has to make a
decision
and so once i went back into the script
with that mandate you know i was able to
wrap it up pretty quickly i was going to
wrap it pretty quickly and pretty
honestly
and with as much truth as possible
and did you give the script to many
people for feedback
no
um
i i think feedback is great sometimes
but when it's something that's very
it was very new for me to be that honest
and that truthful and not try to stick
like you know hollywood
stuff into it hollywood magic to make it
magically resolve
i didn't want that type of feedback
i wanted i wanted it to exist for what
it was
so you didn't need to get notes from
anybody because you self-financed it
and so
you just knew you were but were there
any parts that maybe were unclear that
you wanted people to see and
flesh out for the characters or no you
just knew we were going to do it this
one way i knew i was going to do it that
one way what i did was once i got actors
on board who were
very very talented and they were very
outspoken about their own thoughts on it
um
i was able to just have a conversation
with them where i said free like there
are no wrong answers okay but we're just
going to sit down and we're going to
talk about the script and we're going to
talk about the moments and how we can
make them honest
and very truthful
so let's have those conversations and
like i said it was very productive
because no one was saying but i think it
should end this way or i think i should
do i established very early on
the theme of the movie and where it's
headed is not changing
how we get there may adjust a little bit
but
where this train is headed it already
left the station and it's headed to this
destination
so we all sat down and we said okay cool
in these moments here are things that we
can do to make it more truthful and make
it feel more honest and that's really
what we focused on so there were some
changes along the way but for the most
part
what was on the page was on the screen
for the most part i got i got very very
close i would say
i would say i was 75 there
75 of what i wanted is on the screen
which is a high number for me
what do you tell other screenwriters
filmmakers about being too precious
about certain scenes that maybe they
just don't totally serve the story um
i haven't had to have that conversation
however that conversation was had with
me
and it was had by eddie watkins
he told me he said um
your biggest problem
is that you're married to everything you
do
you can't be that way
especially if you're not the one
financing and directing it you can't be
things are going to have to change for
whatever reason and you're going to have
to be open to making whatever those
changes are work
and that's what i would tell anybody
who's treating it too precious
so because you know we all like want
certain scenes or some little
the artifact in the film and it means
something to us but the audience might
not care
and and so
when people have given you those notes
or maybe it was just ed
are you open to changing them or has it
been hard for you
to take notes
and to remove certain things
um
in the past
i would say i was probably more
open to removing it even if i didn't
agree i'd remove it
because
i want this issue to die and i don't
want things to
keep carrying over or whatever
but once i started to just kind of stand
up and say you know this is this is my
film even if you pay for it it's my film
because ultimately nobody's going to say
you know
well i looked at this movie that
producer must have been great that's not
what they're going to say they're going
to say the director and the writer and
the cast were great that's what they're
going to say and if people know a little
bit more about the industry they're
going to say the cinematographer was
great
but what they're not going to say is wow
that producer really knows his stuff
that just doesn't happen you know and so
what happened is is that we made the
film and we always understood what it
was supposed to be
and then as we got further along
people's
uh
ego started to get involved
and even though i would explain i
understand that this is great for you
but we're at service to the story
not
to you
so the person would relent and so as we
got further into editing
the conversations would come up again
well i think we should really add this
and i'm like you're serving your own ego
you're not really serving the story so
no i don't think we should do that and
so we would go have a little bit back
and forth until i would just say okay
you know what
just so we can
be done with it and then you would cut
it and before you know it it was a movie
that was granted at 2 hours and 15
minutes it's a bit long so we
we cut it down to about maybe
an hour 45 minutes
so now it's cut down
only that needs to happen is color and a
little bit of sound work and it's ready
to be
done so
i handed off and ultimately
i heard through the grapevine that the
film was finished and that it was at an
hour and a half
that's really weird
[Laughter]
it's really weird
something and it was because
i have to take
accountability and responsibility
i handed off the film along with all the
footage
so that it could have the finishing
touches put on it
and what ultimately happened was
this person decided to put all these
scenes back in and remove all these
other scenes so that their work would
stand out a bit more
and it was an ego thing
you know
and i said you know what i i dropped the
ball on that one because i gave that
person the ability to do it that was
that was my fault
and it'll never happen again
it'll never happen again
um because that film floats around and
people say wow that film
and i i can't take
i can't take credit for the good or the
bad because it's not my film
it's not and that was because i started
in the beginning um
we you know talked about
the tv show 24 and jack bauer you know
and the guy says ah you know um
you've never done anything bad you've
never made a bad decision you've never
just done this one little thing and he
says no
because once you do that one little
thing it makes it easier to do the
second thing and the third thing and
that one thing that i did was that i
compromised and i did it just so that
the conversation would die
i said ah
just
and i gave in a little and a little bit
more and a little bit more
and then eventually the film completely
changed
and i said you know i just won't allow
that to happen again if i do work with
someone else the film that they'll
receive to do any type of finishing
touches which by the way i'll do them
all
in house so that when i hand it off it's
a finished film
but let's just say that i had to end it
off they would only get the film to work
with and that would be it
because it's my responsibility to make
sure
that
you know we're honest to the film and
what the film is trying to say we're in
service
of the film
not to our egos